he's finding me you don't shake hands  sit down have a drink  inject on behalf of everybody welcome  back I wanted to come by and personally  say thank you  you making me good money making you good  money  a sweet-talking me I love this guy okay  so when kids you go lucky man  got a bad [ __ ]  but if he is the fire of my loins yes my  crocks furnace Harley Quinn  [Music]  Oh combat daddy pin they said you are my  guests to this handsome hunk ah you  belong to him now you want me I'm all  yours I wanna be you wanna be ill and I  want no beef you like me fine always my  time then this is the lane  look are you enjoying yourself  oh that's your lady circle that's right  okay  you  you